Президент Володимир Зеленський в урочистій промові
з нагоди Дня незалежності України
з гордістю заявив, що майже місяць на сході України
українські військові незазнавали бойових втрат.
Сьогодні 29 днів, як на сході України у нас немає бойових втрат.
29 днів, як українські міста та села не ховають своїх героїв.
29 днів, як не плачуть мами.
29 днів, як дружини та діти чують у телефонній слухавці:
"Цілую вас, мої рідні.
Скоро повернуся додому".
Та чимало з тих, хто почув ці слова Зеленського,
засумнівалися у сказаному очільником держави.
Адже протягом останніх тижнів таки дізнавалися з новин про смерті на передовій.
Так зване "повне та всеосяжне припинення вогню" почалося 27 липня.
Відповідно до зведених даних Операції об'єднаних сил, Міноборони,
та Держприкордонслужби, остання бойова втрата
українських силових структур датована 21-м липня 2020 року.
Після цього до Дня незалежності
минуло навіть не 29, а 34 дні.
Інших бойових втрат силовиками і президентським офісом не зафіксовано.
Загалом станом на 24 серпня офіційно за цей рік Україна
зазнала 47 бойових втрат на сході.
Водночас незалежний портал "Книга пам'яті",
на який посилається чимало людей під постом Зеленського,
повідомляє про загибель 22 серпня в Луганській області офіцера ЗСУ.
31-річний Володимир Рудик з села на Тернопільщині
загинув за нез'ясованих обставин.
Ще раніше, 13 серпня, загинув 49-річний розвідник
Сергій Похович внаслідок підриву авто на міні.
Однак командування ЗСУ
обидві втрати не вважає бойовими.
Адже понад півроку тому Міністерство оборони
затвердило нові рекомендації щодо обліку санітарних втрат особового складу.
Вони істотно відрізняються від того, як рахували загиблих і поранених раніше,
і, як стверджують в Міноборони, відповідають стандартам НАТО.
Згідно з новими критеріями, до безповоротних бойових втрат належать особи,
які загинули під час виконання бойового завдання,
від поранень під час бойової обстановки,
нещасних випадків, знову ж таки, під час виконання бойових завдань.
Натомість до інших, небойових втрат, тепер зараховуються убиті
або смертельно поранені під час несення служби військові,
якщо - цитуємо - це не пов'язано з участю у бойових діях
чи з виконанням бойових завдань.
І вони - в одній категорії з жертвами суїциду,
необережного поводження зі зброєю, аварій та позастатутних відносин.
Саме до цієї категорії "інших загиблих" записали обох військових,
які втратили життя під час "режиму тиші".
Відповідно,це дозволило Зеленському використати в урочистій промові
формулювання про відсутність бойових втрат.
Важливим є те, що коли йдеться про небойову втрату,
штаб Операції об'єднаних сил не може розголошувати інформацію
про обставини загибелі бійця.
Це додатково обмежує можливості перевірити статистику бойових втрат.
Так само на дві категорії – бойові та небойові – поділяють і поранення бійців.
Тож і виходить, що у новинах загиблі фронтовики є,
а у офіційних звітах їх немає.
Критики навіть закидають, що нова класифікація дає змогу владі
статистично зменшувати кількість
бойових втрат на 20-30%.
Твердження президента Володимира Зеленського про відсутність бойових втрат
з українського боку упродовж 29 днів
відповідає офіційній статистиці штабу ООС та Міноборони.
Водночас така заява президента є маніпулятивною,
адже викликає враження абсолютної відсутності жертв на Донбасі,
замовчуючисмерті принаймні двох бійців ЗСУ на передовій у серпні.
Заяву президента зробила можливою нова класифікація,
рекомендована Міністерством оборони.